the one thing my son can do on his own
without any help from his parents is
breathe to have medical professionals
make the judgment that Matthew does not
need any medical services we thought
rageous it's just unthinkable who should
take care of our nation's sick and what
happens when an entire public health
program gets handed over to private
companies the privatization of Medicaid
has really hurt people who most rely on
that program and it's very
heart-wrenching for me they're focused
on money and we're focused on the health
of her son welcome to Iowa a state that
recently privatized Medicaid handing
control of the entire public health
program to for-profit companies iwas
Medicaid system is beginning to collapse
and is collapsing under the weight
agreed it raises serious questions about
our own humanity hey guys I'm Kate and
this Sunday we're in Iowa to put a face
to the people who rely on Medicaid and
find out what happens when a state puts
a crucial social safety net in the hands
of for-profit companies
[Music]
before we get into it remember
Medicaid's that federal program
established back in 1965 that gives
health insurance to our country's poor
elderly and disabled population it's
objectively been a saving grace for
millions of Americans in Iowa about six
hundred thousand people are on it or
about one out of every five people in
the state one of those people receiving
Medicaid is Matthew Hudson who had a
tragic brain bleed which left him
completely paralyzed when he was 16
he's now profoundly disabled and his
parents take care of him we have to feed
him all his meals we bathe him we have
to clothe him we do all his toileting
since the injury 14 years ago Dave
Hudson and his wife have used the
Medicaid money to treat Matthew at their
home this way he doesn't have to go to
an institution which Dave thinks would
be more expensive and impersonal I think
I made the decision that Matthew
deserved to live the best life possible
I'm okay of putting my life aside so
that he can have the best possible life
and that's how it was for the Hudsons
for more than a decade but then in 2016
the governor of Iowa at the time without
any legislative input transfer to every
Iowa Medicaid patient on to plans run by
managed care organizations or what
you'll hear referred to as MC OS the
governor said having these for-profit
companies handle the state's five
billion-dollar Medicaid program would
save taxpayers money and ultimately
would lead to better care but a few
months later the Hudson's got a letter
from their new MCO announcing they were
cutting all of Matthew's Care right here
the reason for the decision is that the
information reviewed fails to establish
medical necessity for the requested
service
when I read that I couldn't believe it
you can't be a medical professional and
tell me that my son does not need any
medical services what message are these
companies sending well I think the
message primarily is we don't care
enough about Matt to pay for the
services he needs if we're gonna make
any money in Iowa then people like your
son who are expensive and chronically
ill he's going to be a drain on our
profits for as long as he's alive Dave
eventually fought the cuts and won but
his struggle isn't unique after the
state hand in Medicaid over to the
health companies there have been
hundreds of stories of Iowans suddenly
being denied crucial coverage and then
getting stuck in an endless cycle of
Appeals to get it back every single week
I get calls from people saying I was
denied service of this or that nature
it's overwhelming as a reporter that's
Jason clay Werth he's an investigative
reporter at the Des Moines Register and
has written dozens of stories about the
fallout of Medicaid privatization one
woman even claims that the privatization
led to her husband's death his wife is
convinced that had he been receiving the
same care that he had received for
decades that her husband would still be
alive these are people that many times
they can't literally speak for
themselves
many of these folks are children they
don't understand their rights for many
of these people it is a matter of life
and death these are serious serious
issues but here's the thing
Iowa is not the only place where this is
happening in fact you probably live in a
state that's privatized Medicaid too
since the 1980s 39 states have done so
in order to save a buck and then what
you critics say happens next when you
get into profit motive well that's your
first goal it's to turn a profit and and
if it needs you to turn a profit at the
expense of other people you do it and by
the way privatization hasn't just meant
that patients are worse off it's been a
crisis for service providers to places
like nursing homes and dental clinics
and rehab
centers many service providers say they
aren't getting reimbursed from the MC OS
which means they have to cut back on
staff and services I've had medical
doctors who have called me who have
actually said up until this point I
always felt it was part of my duty as a
doctor to take Medicaid and to serve
them but I am to the point with
frustration with the managed care
organizations where I am on the edge and
ready to just stop taking Medicaid all
together when that happens families are
left with knowing to go to for their
child's medical care give it back to the
state they didn't have problems when the
state took care of it
that's Joanne fazenda her son Louie is a
26 year old with cerebral palsy Joanne
told me that a few months after Louie's
Medicaid was moved to an MCO all his
care was cut including his medication it
was it was a nightmare it was it was
literally a nightmare of what am I going
to do I can't afford all that medication
also cut where his daily nurse visits so
for six weeks Louie went without the
in-home bathing and diaper changing he
had had for years he wasn't getting
changed like he would normally get
changed two or three times or more a day
she was in a dirty brief from like in
the morning till 7:00 o'clock at night
and all this just because some company
decided that he didn't need these
services it wasn't just the services it
was the mental part of his his state of
mind not understanding why all this was
happening and I would cry for him
because I felt so bad at this point
you're probably wondering how these
private companies have responded to
these horrible stories well listen to
how one doctor at one of the MCO s
justified denying diaper-changing
services people have bowel movements
every day where they don't completely
clean themselves and we don't fuss over
too much people are allowed to be dirty
you know I would allow him to be a
little dirty for a couple days would you
say to him if you could
to be honest yeah right Louie you like
to be clean I think it's horrible I
don't know I don't have words for that I
reached out to several people for this
video including the current Republican
governor and the health companies no one
agreed to speak with me on camera they
also didn't respond to written questions
in an email either but I did get
template statements back extolling the
virtues of managed care I also tried to
reach out to Iowa Medicaid director Mike
Randall and by the way he's the same guy
responsible for a similar privatization
fiasco in Kansas which the federal
government recently denounced as being
quote subsequently out of compliance
with US law Randall explicitly avoided
me at a public meeting but his press
department told me in an email
quote the department is committed to
improving quality and access to care
promoting accountability for patient
outcomes and creating a more predictable
and sustainable Medicaid budget they
also referred me to a study that ranks
Iowa's health care systems second in the
nation for patient satisfaction but
Jason told me that study is dubious they
will cite surveys that they can't
provide the specific questions that were
asked or the number of recipients that
they asked the question - so for all we
know they asked seven people we don't
know no politician will say that they
are out to harm the elderly or the poor
but their actions speak louder than
words and what about this idea that the
state will eventually save money well in
Iowa the estimates of savings have
varied wildly without much explanation
and a national report on privatized
Medicaid showed that yes some states
with managed care did save some money
but that quote the weight of the
evidence suggests any potential savings
will not be significant and people like
Dave Hudson say even if money is being
saved on the backs of who it doesn't
bother me if the number is one dollar or
two hundred million dollars it doesn't
bother me what concerns me is where the
savings come from
what had to be reduced in order for the
state to make ax to save 141 million
dollars my supposition is that the
savings came from considerable
reductions and Medicaid Services
everyone should care about Medicaid
because every one of us is an illness or
an accident away from needing it someday
none of us know our future holds but
what I do know is that if that happens
to you that you have a safety net in
place called Medicaid my experience with
Medicaid in Iowa has only reinforced my
belief that our nation needs to move
toward a single-payer universal system
I'm not certain that my son is safe with
the Republican governor and a Republican
legislature the MCO and I say that as a
lifelong Republican they're focused on
money and we're focused on the health of
our son hey everyone thank you so much
for watching because facts I hope you
appreciated this deep dive we did into a
pretty complicated topic please remember
to Like share and subscribe for more
videos like this and hey while you're at
it check out some of the coverage that
the Des Moines Register did around this
topic it really helped us understand the
issue you can check out a link to the
two their coverage in the description
below thank you so much for watching and
we'll see you next week